back in the early 2000s hayden
panettiere was
everywhere from her role in the popular
series heroes
to plum parts in rom-coms like i love
you beth cooper
she made her rounds in hollywood for all
that exposure however
panettiere has largely faded from public
view
panettiere rose to mainstream prominence
by starring as claire bennett on heroes
for a while the show was enormously
popular and
uniquely headline making something of a
predecessor to the ever-expanding world
of tv series
we know today those who were around for
its burst of success will likely recall
its infamous tagline say the cheerleader
save the world claire bennett is this
very cheerleader
and was featured prominently in the
show's promotional campaigns
claire has the power of cellular
regeneration which allows her to heal
quickly from injuries
and become practically immortal when she
initially discovers her powers she's
both curious
and frightened and eventually realizes
that her own fate
might be tied to that of the entire
world
heroes didn't just earn the public's
acclaim critics initially responded to
it with glowing praise as well
the first season inspired widespread
excitement
scoring multiple wins and nominations
from a wide variety of industry awards
including the golden globes and the
emmys but in later seasons
heroes ratings took a tumble it began to
feel as though the writers had no real
plan for giving the show a satisfying
conclusion
and the narrative became increasingly
ludicrous and convoluted
unfortunately for panettiere heroes has
become remembered for its stellar first
season and not much else in the end the
show was cancelled on a low note
which very well might have impacted
panettiere's career
when panettiere started her career as a
child actor she worked on soap operas
television movies
and the occasional miniseries disney
came calling in the late 1990s
leading to her roles as dot in a bug's
life
and surrey in dinosaur soon after she
landed a memorable role
in the football hit remember the titans
as she got
older and made a name for herself on
heroes panettiere found
swift and dazzling success but it came
with a price
she quickly found that she was being
typecast she had already played a
talented ice skater and high school
student in
ice princess and now she was playing a
cheerleader on heroes
she also starred as a cheerleader in
both bring it on all or nothing
and i love you beth cooper a theme was
developing
and she wanted out she told contact
music
if i don't get out of this category
pretty quickly it will just get more and
more difficult to be seen as anything
besides a cheerleader
like you get in a corset it's hard to
get out of a corset
again as fans of nashville know
panittiere is one heck of a talented
singer but somehow
her real world music career never really
got off the ground
panettiere made her way down the early
sections of the disney actress to pop
star path
recording songs for several disney
movies including ice princess
and cinderella 3 a twist in time she
even started working on her own album
releasing a single entitled wake-up call
in 2008
but she wasn't happy with the music that
her record label was pushing her to sing
and has since revealed her
dissatisfaction with this release
she said in an interview with vulture at
that point
i was a puppet basically it wasn't me
however
these unpleasant experiences in the
music industry have proved useful to her
as an actress
while playing juliet an aspiring singer
and one of the main roles on nashville
panettiere took her experiences into
account as her character was encouraged
to record
music she was not passionate about when
i read this script
and it became that for juliet i was like
i understand
i know what that is though things ended
positively in this regard
she doesn't think she'll try to record
another album in the future as she feels
that people will conflate her music with
her character
after having her daughter kaia in
december 2014
panettiere found herself struggling with
postpartum depression
she sought treatment multiple times
ultimately checking into a utah
treatment center for support in may
2016.
she has repeatedly chosen to share her
struggles as she believes greater
openness about the condition
can help other women who suffer from the
condition in an interview with good
morning america
she said it takes you a while and and
you feel
off you don't feel like yourself but you
know
women are so resilient and that's the
incredible thing about them
she went on to say i think i'm all the
stronger for it
i think i'm a better mom because of it
because you never take that connection
for granted
today hayden's daughter kaia lives with
her father former boxer vladimir
klitschko
in ukraine naturally she still wants to
spend as much time with her daughter as
possible so she travels to ukraine
whenever she gets the chance
it's easy to imagine this might be a big
part of why panettiere doesn't always
have the free time to commit to new
roles
although they've been separated for
several years now panettiere and
klitschko enjoy a genuinely amicable
bond
and seek to set a positive example for
their daughter she told us magazine
we're still respectful of each other and
we still have that friendship with each
other it's not a situation that you find
yourself
in all that often so it's a new one but
i think we've done a really good job
it may seem contradictory to say that a
celebrity like panettiere is
actually a very private person but
that's the truth unlike so many highly
visible stars
panettiere makes a point of not making
every detail of her life public
while she does share her struggles with
fans when she's ready like her battle
with postpartum depression
she rarely posts on instagram or twitter
it's a far cry from the ultra-connected
world of many stars
who have multiple feeds updating on an
hourly basis
it seems that panettiere chooses to stay
out of the public eye to the fullest
extent
she can these days and it's not
necessarily because of a lack of
opportunities
while plenty of celebrities enjoy
sharing their day-to-day lives on social
media
panettiere has strong boundaries when it
comes to privacy
as panettiere tried to move forward in
her career
and break away from her cheerleader
image she took on a majorly
controversial role
in 2011 she starred as amanda knox the
college student who was convicted of the
murder of meredith kercher
in amanda knox murder on trial in italy
in the real world knox was eventually
exonerated when another
man was identified as the murderer and
has since spoken openly
about her ordeal kircher's family was
unhappy with the contents of the film
especially because it depicts a
fictionalized version of kircher's
murder
john kercher meredith's father said in
an interview with time
it's so awful what these film people
have done your imagination runs riot as
it is about what happened but to
actually see it like this
is very different and very distressing i
was told the original brief and synopsis
of the film was to take it up to the
point of the killing but not actually
show the killing itself
it's obvious from these pictures they
are showing the killing
while panettiere may have had good
intentions when she accepted the role
it's clear that this film was deeply
upsetting for those who lived through
these events
after she began working on nashville
panettiere decided to pack up
and move to the city for which the show
is named she purchased a home in
nashville and subsequently realized that
she was much happier living there
instead of in new york city or los
angeles she felt like she could be more
laid back
and more true to herself moreover she
told southern living that she
appreciated that her new neighbors
seemed to value the little things in
life
allowing her to slow down and stop
focusing on the non-stop hustle of life
in the entertainment industry
she continued the people here are
amazing living in nashville gives me a
sense of normalcy that i wasn't
sure i was ever going to get back in my
life when i first got here
all my defenses were still up and i was
waiting for that world to suddenly creep
back
in when it didn't i realized that i can
live a normal life here with people who
don't judge you based on what you do
or who you are in the public eye
recently
panettiere has opened up about her
struggle to leave an abusive
relationship
in the summer of 2020 her ex-boyfriend
brian hickerson
was arrested on several charges of
domestic abuse
now panettiere is speaking out about
what happened
and why she hopes her story can help
other people who are in similar
situations
break free i am coming forward with the
truth about what happened to me
with the hope that my story will empower
others in abusive relationships to get
the help they need
and deserve i am prepared to do my part
to make sure this man
never hurts anyone again now she's
focusing on herself
and rebuilding her life for panettiere
stepping away from the camera for a
while has been necessary
after going through such a traumatic
experience she wants to put her health
and well-being first healing has to take
priority
happily she has found the courage to
speak out and has surrounded herself
with supportive people panettiere is
well known for her activism
particularly in regards to animal
welfare after appearing on heroes
she realized that she could use her new
platform for good
she told teen vogue the show put me in a
place to speak for the things that i'm
passionate about
panettiere joined up with the whale man
foundation in 2007 to protest
dolphin hunting she was personally
involved in a confrontation between a
group of fishermen
and several surfers in japan who had
arrived to protest the annual dolphin
hunt
in taiji this incident is explored in
the 2009 documentary the cove
which analyzes this annual dolphin hunt
and offers viewers a call to action for
the welfare of these animals
today panettiere still serves as a
spokesperson for the whale man
foundation
she told conde nast traveler in an
interview
i'm an activist who's aware of what's
realistic to achieve and what's not
the whale man foundation's goals are
achievable and they make
sense it goes without saying that this
level of devotion to a cause would
hinder any actress's ability to remain
steadfast in hollywood's spotlight
in 2018 the final episode of nashville
aired
ending panettiere's six-year run as
juliet barnes
since then she has not appeared in any
other television shows or movies
currently she does not have much in the
way of future roles lined up
either at this point it looks like
panettiere is purposefully enjoying a
well-earned hiatus
and that she does not have any immediate
plans to get back
in front of the camera considering
everything panettiere has gone through
over the course of the past decade it's
easy to see why she feels the need to
take some time off
from acting she's welcomed a daughter
battled postpartum depression
and spoken out about abuse that's enough
to push anyone to the brink
but she has not made any statements
about retiring
meaning she'll likely be back on screen
in the future
in the meantime fans of her work will be
waiting to see what her next move
is there's no denying her talent when
panettiere does decide to act
sing or campaign again she'll certainly
enjoy
a warm welcome back check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one